SOMETHING FOR THE AUTO INDUSTRY.
BRET.
>> Bret: JOHN, THANK YOU.
THE DOW STAGING A VERY MODEST
COMEBACK TODAY, FINISHING AHEAD
188.
THE S&P 500 WAS UP 11, THE
NASDAQ SURGED 1621 TODAY.
SUSAN LI OF FOX BUSINESS JOINS
US NOW, GOOD EVENING SUSAN.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
A SMALL RECOVERY FROM THREE YEAR
LOWS, THEY ARE HOPING FOR A BIG
ECONOMIC STIMULUS PACKAGE FROM
WASHINGTON.
IT HAS BEEN PUMPING MONEY IN AND
TRYING TO HELP CUSHION THE
FINANCIAL FALLOUT.
AMERICA’S BIG TECHNOLOGY NAMES
LEADING THE REBOUND TODAY,
AMAZON, FACEBOOK, NETFLIX, AND
MICROSOFT.
AMAZON HAD ITS FIRST EMPLOYEE
WAREHOUSE EMPLOYEE TESTING POSIT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HINTED THAT THE
U.S. MIGHT INTERVENE IN THE OIL
MARKET.
OIL STILL DOWN TO 60% ON THE
YEAR, AS ARE THE AIRLINES AND
BOWLING.
AIRLINES ARE LOOKING FOR
$50 BILLION IN ASSISTANCE FROM
THE GOVERNMENT, BOEING IS ASKING
FOR 60 MILLION.
>> WE WILL BE HELPING THE
AIRLINE INDUSTRY, AND THE
CRUISE SHIP INDUSTRY.
WE PROBABLY WILL BE HELPING THE
HOTEL INDUSTRY.
WE WILL PROBABLY, WHERE JOBS ARE
CREATED.
YOU DON’T WANT TO LOSE
INDUSTRIES LIKE THIS.
>> THERE IS LOUD CRITICISM THAT
SAID THAT BAILOUTS SHOULD COME
WITH LIMITS.
>> NO BUYBACKS, NOT NOW, NOT A
YEAR FROM NOW, NOT 20 YEARS FROM
NOW, NOT EVER.
EFFECTIVELY, YOU ARE SPENDING
TAXPAYER MONEY TO BUY BACK STOCK
AND TO ME, THAT IS THE WRONG WAY
TO DO THAT.
>> CERTAIN COMPANIES, AS YOU
KNOW, IT’S VERY HARD TO TELL
THEM NOT TO BUT I WOULD TELL
THEM NOT TO.
I DON’T LIKE IT FOR THAT REASON.
>> SHARE BUYBACKS USUALLY LIFT
THE STOCK CRISIS BECAUSE THEY
REDUCE SUPPLY AND THAT WOULD
BENEFIT COMPANY EXECUTIVES.
MEANTIME, FOR SMALL BUSINESS,
96% OF OWNERS SAY THEY ARE
ALREADY BEING HEARD BY THE
CORONAVIRUS IN A SURVEY BY
GOLDMAN SACHS.
BANK OF AMERICA SAYS THE U.S. IS